in the first installment of three Bungie
live streams this morning it was
announced that it a conversion of the
prison of elders will be making its way
into the Destiny universe on April 12
the light level cap has also been raised
from 322 335 changes to the prison
include up to max level weapons and
armor drops checkpoints for your potty
breaks ability to complete regular
bounties and a new challenge of the
elder sigil that works in similar
fashion to the cards from trials of
Osiris the level 41 arena with a
recommended light level of 260 is
confirmed for matchmaking however the
level 42 arena at flight level 320 is
old-fashioned bring your own fireteam
cards can be picked up once a week and
include a weekly high-score challenge
currently 30,000 points for a guaranteed
weapon and the tougher cumulative score
challenge that's on a sliding scale and
nets guaranteed armor at ninety thousand
points other confirmed features of the
April update include eight new bosses
one new strike who's boss name is Malik
one taken modified strike winters run
and 16 new challenges which should last
about four months without repeating also
spotted during the live stream was new
tech and Guardian armor or perhaps a
shader and what appears to be a taken
shotgun the new content seems to lay out
a path for casual destiny players who've
walked away from the game to come back
and get to max level as your guardian /
Guardians been sitting sadly in the
tower lately will this update tear you
away from the division or fallout 4s new
DLC utama tron feel free to give your
thoughts in the comments below and for
more coverage of destiny stay tuned to
gamespot com
you